this is sal and this is vi
and we wanted to make an announcement
yes i'm very excited here let me draw oh
no you're off off the screen oh no
that's because this thing is there there
i got it all right nope i'm off now you
need to use the pen tool oh my god press
the paint brush right there there we go
all right okay not now you're in
business now i can be vi hey um
um
and the exciting thing that happened
is that sal and i are joining forces
like uh like
maybe the seed of a league of
of video mate well yes we're joining
forces that's kind of the way i think of
it i think it's like superheroes coming
together to try and and save the world
from bad fight mathematical ignorance
yes another ignorance or or lack of
mathematical inspiration too not just
ignorance not just ignorance yes so
we're joining forces we uh
vai has now moved to mountain view
california she is part of the khan
academy team but she will continue to be
i mean you could say doing what you're
already doing yeah um sal has just
offered me this extraordinary
opportunity to basically do
what i've been doing what i want he's
not going to be telling me what to do
and he gives me money and uh i can not
that's not me the organization well the
organization yes khan academy gives you
money that's this is not not sell
personally yes and now you don't have to
exactly you can just focus on making
awesome videos
yeah which is kind of crazy because i uh
you know i offer my videos for free i
um it's not like khan academy has
exclusive rights and you have to go
there and pay the money for what i'm
doing no it's still all
yes so i know i still think it's crazy
that i get to do this too and i think
give it to people that we all get to do
this for but it's good for the world so
it's it's good
the world sometimes does hopefully do
good things hopefully
yeah so how did this happen i i saw your
videos and i thought they were awesome
and so uh i and i was just talking
divide just then so but now i'll talk to
you who is listening uh so i contacted
vi and i said well what you're doing is
is awesome you know are you able to do
this and you know in a sustainable way
and i i what i got from you is kind of
yeah well i was mostly living off of
speaking fees
which
is fun and i like traveling and speaking
but it takes a lot of time and energy to
be traveling around speaking yes exactly
so so we said well would you want to
join forces with us and one that'll
allow you to keep making these awesome
videos uh we would then
get more videos that maybe we could also
integrate with the stuff that we already
produce uh so that you know kids can get
even more inspiration on mathematics and
uh frankly we were we were also
intrigued by a lot of the projects that
vi had been working on and uh one of the
things that khan academy is starting to
focus on in a very serious way is
not just the traditional academic
subjects but how do we get kids more
hands and more engaged with the subject
matter in a hands-on way and so we've
been experimenting with some we're going
to start having a summer camp and we're
going to experiment with different types
of projects and vi's got all sorts of
neat ideas and so that too was
kind of awesome yeah i already got to
tag along with part of the khan academy
team to a school and do some workshops
there with the kids which was a lot of
fun
yes and we had i actually i
unfortunately wasn't there but i heard
great things about it
yeah well actually i don't think
everyone even knows who we are and what
we do
oh you're right because yeah because i'm
right because the people who are used to
khan academy know who i am but they
might not know who you are and the
people who know you won't know who i am
yes right so you want to go first um
sure i can
oh am i talking about you or am i no no
talk about yourself talk about yourself
you know yourself better yeah i don't i
don't um but if i knew myself oh i'm
gonna talk about you is that easier
because then you can like i i can say
things that would not be modest for you
to say
i don't know i do so i'll talk i'll talk
yeah yeah so vi
vi is a youtube phenomenon she has a uh
i guess she's most known for for her
these
videos and i guess there's a similarity
in what we do and that you don't see us
you in your videos they are real videos
you see your hands
but you mainly focus on what you're
producing you're drawing stuff and in my
videos too you only see what i'm drawing
but you don't even see my hands and
that's that's a good thing uh and and so
and and vi's videos and and she has her
own youtube channel
huge following they're fun they're smart
they're inspirational uh you you fashion
yourself as a math musician yes yes
because because you you're right that's
my job right that is that is your job
title yes we're printing the business
cards so you're the nexus of of the two
or maybe even other things and and
yeah and she's an all-around
inspirational person to hang out with
wow that sounded good you're welcome
yeah more like that yeah um
so what sal is doing and has done is
he's making really just educational and
clear videos that actually teach you
things in just such a wonderfully
clear way
and um well it obviously works because
millions of how how many millions of
people
watch your videos every month unique
viewers soon to be your videos so
although many people already watch your
videos you get hundreds of thousands of
people watching your videos but it's a
uh we're at four million unique users
now every month and and it is we because
it's going to be all of us and not just
sal not just vibe but we have a team of
20 other people uh beth and steven are
making art history videos and we have an
amazing software platform made by people
far more impressive than myself uh
and and so that whole experience four
million people right now so it's it's
been a um
yeah which is really
really cool when it comes to just math
education it's all for we're giving it
all away and we're all not all for free
any of you so people often ask me hey vi
i like your videos but you know i i want
to actually like learn some stuff for
real and i'll learn something
from your videos but yes well i i hope
to inspire i just want to share kind of
cool stuff you can do and it is very
important also to be able to amuse
yourself during class yes
that's where i learned everything i know
but being able to amuse yourself is a
great skill so i like to teach people
that but when people ask me you know how
do i go farther than that how do i
really get down some basics and khan
academy is just such a perfect way to do
this so i recommend everyone to go and
and there's even achievements it's
there's a lot of great things it's not
just videos i think yeah so that's what
we're excited about we we hope to inject
some of advised dna also into the
software itself we'll have ideas on new
types of projects new types of
simulations and all the rest so expect
to expect to see many many things from
us
yes
and it's going to be awesome and yes
i'll reiterate that now we have the what
is this thing right over here this is
scripting this url this cryptic url
the url of my site or of your site
um which i guess iheart.com and khan
academy.org
uh i wanted another color there oh good
yes that is a url for
we're running a little google moderator
thing and so the plan is because this is
what we think is a pretty exciting
announcement
we want you guys to ask us questions
about what we're up to they don't have
to just be about
how we're going to work together there
could be any questions about anything
but you go there put your question in
and then you can vote on which questions
you want to see most and then in about a
week we will answer them via video and
hopefully that will
answer your questions
yeah i think it's a good opportunity to
ask us whatever you want
sounds good well we look forward to
seeing your questions yes